[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mercredi 11 janvier voici le
programme dans cette émission nous
reviendrons sur la réforme des retraites
annoncé hier soir par la première
ministre Elisabeth borne 64 ans c'est
l'âge auquel les Français pourront
partir en retraite avec 43 à nuités
Olivier Véran le porte-parole du
gouvernement était à Coignières cet
après-midi pour échanger avec les
salariés de l'entreprise Ihab nous en
parlerons en détail avec Grégory canalet
journaliste de la rédaction de TV 78
tout au long de ce mois de janvier nous
recevons les maires de l'agglomération
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour
évoquer les grands projets de l'année
2023 dans leur commune ce soir focus sur
Guyancourt quartier des savoirs
transition écologique Grand Paris
Express nous ferons le point avec
François Morton le de la ville boulanger
restaurateur commerçant face à la hausse
du prix de l'énergie et des matières
premières comment font-ils face au
quotidien les aides mises en place par
le gouvernement sont-elles efficaces et
suffisantes Olivier Gérard président de
la Fédération des boulangers et
pâtissiers des Yvelines répondra à nos
questions et avec moi en plateau Eric
Alain Genesse bonsoir alors vous êtes
mère adjoint à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
vous êtes également vice-président de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines mais vous êtes
aussi médecin et c'est au médecin qu'on
s'adresse ce soir puisqu'il y a eu
depuis plusieurs semaines une grève des
médecins alors plusieurs revendications
notamment à la hausse du prix des
consultations qui passeraient de 25 à 50
euros alors première question est-ce que
vous vous avez fait grève en tant que
médecin
oui j'ai fait grève alors une grève
aménagée bien évidemment j'ai assuré les
urgences pour les exerce dans un cabinet
je suis seul dans mon cabinet est
évident qu'on allait pas abandonner les
patients à leur sort mais bien
évidemment je me suis associé à ce
mouvement de grève bien sûr donc vous
nous donnerez les raisons de pourquoi
vous avez fait grève un peu plus tard
dans cette émission avec nous également
Déborah Agnès bonsoir bonsoir alors vous
êtes infirmière puéricultrice à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et vous proposez
des bains pour les bébés alors ça
consiste en quoi alors c'est ce qu'on
appelle le vin thalasso bébé ou le bain
thérapeutique
c'est un bain qui permet aux bébés de
retrouver des sensations qu'il avait
dans le ventre de maman et qui lui donne
la possibilité de pouvoir
débloquer des choses émotionnelles ou
des tensions corporelles à travers ce
bain pour pouvoir mieux appréhender la
suite ça peut être aussi un moment juste
de lâcher prise tout simplement mais en
général il y a quand même une
thérapeutique derrière aussi bien pour
bébé que pour les parents et donc on en
parlera un peu plus en détail tout à
l'heure dans cette émission aussi comme
d'habitude les informations du jour le
coup de coeur ciné d'un professionnel du
7e art et les sorties dans les salles de
cette semaine mais avant jetons un coup
d'œil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin le ciel le devrait être
plus vieux sur l'ensemble du département
le vent sera également bien présent nous
devrions avoir des rafales devant à 65
km/h au niveau des températures il fera
10 à 11 degrés en moyenne dans
l'après-midi pas de grands changements
perspective la pluie devrait rester au
rendez-vous tout comme le vent au niveau
des températures il fera entre 11 et 12
degrés et demain un nous fêterons les
Tatiana le point maintenant sur
l'actualité du jour
et c'est avec vous Mélanie poquet on
commence par les soldes c'était le top
départ aujourd'hui et oui jusqu'au 7
février ce sont les soldes d'hiver des
soldes dans un contexte d'inflation les
professionnels pour être tentés de faire
des démarques cette année un peu moins
importantes selon le directeur général
de l'Alliance du commerce les mois
d'octobre et novembre n'ont pas été très
bon contrairement à décembre et après
deux années de covid les commerçants
auraient des stocks raisonnables et
demain soir dans votre 7 8 nous
reviendrons plus en détail sur le
lancement de ces sols de divers nous
aurons notamment des commerçants en
plateau pour venir témoigner on continue
ces informations du jour Mélanie par les
vœux du département des Yvelines et des
Hauts-de-Seine chaque année alors hier
soir mardi 10 janvier les Yvelines et
les Hauts-de-Seine présentaient leurs
vœux lors d'une cérémonie après trois
ans sans rassemblement conjoint en
raison du covid un rendez-vous qui s'est
déroulé au Haras de Jardy à
Marnes-la-Coquette une ville proche du
78 parmi les grands dossiers à venir la
ligne 18 et son prolongement pardon
super say à Nanterre l'occasion aussi de
remettre à l'ordre du jour la volonté de
fusionner les deux départements une
fusion engagée en 2016 entre Pierre BD
et Patrick devejan décédé du covid en
2020 la fusion dépend de l'état l'État
ne nous répond pas mais ça ne nous
empêche pas effectivement de continuer à
mettre en commun parce que c'est plus
efficace c'est moins coûteux c'est plus
intelligent et donc oui on continue à
avancer moi j'attends j'espère une vraie
et grande loi de décentralisation qui
refixe bien les choses l'État sur le
régalien où on voit de façon qu'il a du
mal
notre système de santé va pas bien
l'éducation nationale va pas bien là je
suis pas pas bien la sécurité va pas
bien enfin je peux multiplier les
exemples même l'énergie bientôt n'est
même plus indépendant voilà donc c'est
qu'il se reconcentre l'État sur ces
missions première et que du coup il a né
les moyens et que sur le reste et bien
il donne
liberté le pouvoir de faire aux
collectivités que nous sommes c'est une
information de nos confrères de 7-8actus
des familles de résidences suspectes des
maltraitances dans un EHPAD à Maurepas
de famille de résidents mais aussi des
membres du personnel qui témoignent dans
l'article et dressent un tableau assez
noir des perfusions qui sont retrouvés
par terre des draps qui ne sont pas
régulièrement changer des toilettes
expédiées par manque de personnel et des
résidents parfois retrouvés avec des
hématomes la direction réfutent ces
alliations on part maintenant à
Magny-les-Hameaux avec une antenne
mobile inédite on connaissait les food
truck voici les jobstrucks le
département a lui son bus job insertion
il y a Mani les hameau il y a un job
truc qui s'installe une fois par mois
sur le parvis de l'hôtel de ville et à
l'esplanade Gérard Philipe Dubuisson
s'est organisé par trois associations
chantiers Yvelines défis service plus et
CBL réagir alors si vous recherchez un
emploi ou que vous recherchez un employé
les équipes du jobstock vous
accompagnent dans vos projets les
prochains rendez-vous les premiers vins
de février et le 15 mars et le chiffre
du jour Mélanie c'est 1467
c'est le nombre d'heures de cours perdus
par les élèves dans le département des
Yvelines alors c'est un chiffre qui a
été calculé par la plateforme où il y a
pas cours de la Fédération des parents
d'élèves la FCPE cela concerne le
premier comme le second degré un peu de
sport à présent Mélanie oui on va parler
de Léo barré on en parler régulièrement
sur notre antenne 3/4 polyvalent du
Stade Français il est pressenti pour
jouer lors du prochain tournoi des 6
nations ce sera une première pour lui et
que le 15 de France Fabien Galtier le
sélectionneur de l'équipe de France la
cité dans un entretien dans les colonnes
du Midi Olympique les hauts barré et il
est originaire de Versailles il a déjà
joué sous les couleurs tricolores mais
cette fois dans l'équipe des moins de 20
ans et on termine par un anniversaire
oui celui d'un des Monuments français
les plus célèbres le château de
Versailles fête ses 400 ans cette année
en 1623 le roi Louis XII prend la
décision de faire bâtir dans la futur
cité royale un petit relais de chasse il
est résidera à partir du mois de juin
1624 avant de le faire repartir rebâtir
à partir de 1631 le monument tel qu'on
le connaît aujourd'hui lui on le doit au
Roi Soleil Louis XIV merci beaucoup
Mélanie poquet et si vous aussi comme
d'habitude vous voyez une information
qui vous a marqué près de chez vous
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager en
utilisant le hashtag 78
[Musique]
hier la première ministre Elisabeth
borne a détaillé les contours de la
réforme des retraites âge légal de
départ reculé à 64 ans en 2030
cotisation allongée à 43 à nuités des
2027 pour une retraite une retraite à
taux plein voici quelques-unes démesures
alors qu'une mobilisation sociale est
déjà prévue pour le 19 janvier
l'exécutif est désormais sur le terrain
pour expliquer son projet de loi Grégory
canalet vous y était d'ailleurs bonsoir
vous avez suivi le déplacement de
Olivier Véran le porte-parole du
gouvernement il est venu à la rencontre
des salariés à kway à Coignières dans
l'entreprise Ihab alors est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire un peu plus
une entreprise spécialisée dans la
manutention embarquée sur camion et qui
est implanté à Coignières depuis un an
désormais sur site 45 salariés
qu'Olivier Véran a rencontré au cours de
son déplacement il était accompagné de
la députée de la 10ème circonscription
des Yvelines Aurore berger qui est aussi
présidente du groupe Renaissance à
l'Assemblée nationale alors le but d'ici
l'examen et projet de loi c'est de faire
de la pédagogie auprès des Français on
écoute Olivier Véran quand on interpelle
de prime abord les salariés c'est pas le
premier sujet qu'ils ont à la bouche
mais quand on les interroge et bien
évidemment il y a de l'inquiétude
certains se demandent s'ils vont devoir
travailler plus longtemps et on a vu là
plusieurs profils de salariés ensuite il
y a un effort effectivement
d'information à réaliser de notre part
pour vraiment expliquer à l'ensemble des
Français c'était le cas aussi avec
quelques salariés avec qui nous avons pu
échanger sur pourquoi nous réformons les
retraites ils sont tous conscience que
c'est leur cotisation actuelle qui paye
la retraite de leurs parents et de leurs
grands-parents quand ils sont quand ils
sont retraités il y a des interrogations
sur la nécessité de rééquilibrer ce
régime est-ce que vraiment il est en
déficit etc donc c'est notre mission
dans les dans les prochains jours avant
que le texte soit présenté en Conseil
des ministres et avant qu'il soit
débattu au Parlement que d'aller à la
rencontre des Français comme nous le
faisons aujourd'hui et fort
d'information l'entendait dans le son
précédent parce que si c'est vrai que
parmi les salariés qui ont échangé avec
le ministre tous savent à peu près une
réforme se prépare mais peut ça vraiment
ce que contient le projet de loi il s'y
intéresse pas forcément davantage en
tout cas c'est ça a été vrai sur parmi
les salariés qu'Olivier Véran a
rencontré sur place regardez par exemple
cette séquence avec un jeune
chaudronnier soudeur de 22 ans bon vous
êtes intéressé un peu à la réforme des
retraites tout ça ou c'est pas du tout
votre truc c'est quoi c'est je vous dis
retraite vous dites quoi oh là là pour
le moment je dirais que j'entends pas
que du bien de ce côté là mais bon là je
me sens pas encore trop concerné et pour
vous que vous avez pas regardé du tout
parce que c'est impliqué non pas pour le
moment pas pour le moment là ça fait un
an que je suis là c'est mon premier
boulot j'ai pas pensé à la retraite tout
ça
on rappelle le but de cette réforme en
tout cas ce qui est annoncé par le
gouvernement et par Elisabeth borne ça
vise à préserver l'équilibre du système
des retraites par répartition qui est
voué selon le gouvernement au déficit
s'il n'y a pas de modification et à
freiner aussi les défenses les dépenses
publiques est-ce que vous pouvez nous
rappeler ce qui a été annoncé alors dans
les grandes lignes là réforme prévoit
notamment le recul de l'âge légal du
départ à la retraite de 62 à 64 ans
recule qui sera progressif de trois mois
par année qui attendra la cible des 64
ans en 2030 l'allongement de la durée de
cotisation à 43 à nuités dès 2027 au
lieu de 2035 pour toucher une retraite à
taux plein le minimum de pension est
relevé à 85% du SMIC pour les retraites
complètes soit 1200 euros brut par mois
le dispositif des carrières longues et
révisé enfin le principe les principaux
régimes spéciaux sont supprimés alors
dans cette entreprise de Coignières
c'est une réforme qui ne semble pas plus
inquiéter que ça
le sujet au sein de notre entreprise on
aura peut-être des retours et on verra
bien ce que ce que les gens ce que les
gens pensent mais on le voit on l'a
entendu pas vraiment d'hostilités sur
place peut-être que l'entreprise n'a pas
été choisie tout à fait par hasard par
les équipes d'Olivier Véran pour appeler
le calendrier de cette réforme des
retraites la présentation devant le
Conseil des Ministres est prévu pour le
23 janvier le projet de loi était
examiné en commission à l'Assemblée
nationale à partir du 30 janvier et dans
l'hémicycle appartient du SI février
vous l'aviez dit tout à l'heure Mathilde
les syndicats ont d'ores et déjà annoncé
une première journée de mobilisation
sociale le jeudi 19 janvier
Grégory vous étiez sur place est-ce que
c'est une un déplacement une visite qui
a été suivi par beaucoup de journalistes
un sujet qui intéresse directement les
rédactions il y avait une dizaine de
rédaction à peu près 8 ou 9 caméras sur
place donc c'était vrai que c'était
difficile dans cette petite entreprise
de Coignières alors avec des entrepôts
assez grands tout de même de se créer un
chemin pour pouvoir tendre son micro au
porte-parole du gouvernement j'allais
dire Premier ministre il est
porte-parole du gouvernement
merci beaucoup Grégory canalet on vous
retrouve un petit peu plus tard tout à
l'heure pour les sorties ciné de cette
semaine on en parlait en début
d'émission durant tout le mois de
janvier TV 78 reçoit les maires de
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines pour parler des grands projets
de l'année 2023 et ce soir nous recevons
François Morton bonsoir vous êtes le
maire de la commune de Guyancourt vous
allez présenter vos vœux au
Guyancourtois et guyancourtoise le 14
janvier alors qu'est-ce que vous allez
évoquer avec eux on va faire évidemment
un petit bilan de cette année écoulé
avec l'ensemble des mesures qu'on a dû
les uns et les autres et
particulièrement à Guyancourt mettre en
place je vais pas refaire l'histoire de
ces dernières années mais pour un
certain nombre d'entre nous nous sommes
les maires du covid de la guerre de la
crise énergétique et donc on commence
habitué à être habitué un petit peu
assez crises et on réagit concrètement
et rapidement avec beaucoup de
réactivité dans les communes je pense
notamment à la mise en place de
nouvelles aides énergétiques pour nos
habitants euh des aides qui par le passé
relever d'autres collectivités mais
maintenant qui qui sont des aides
communales je pense aux allocations
énergie pour les personnes âgées pour
les familles monoparentales que nous
venons d'inaugurer cette année par le
fait évidemment ou
détendre encore une fois
aux personnes notamment en situation de
handicap également nous allons accélérer
aussi l'ensemble des réhabilitations des
bâtiments publics parce que ça a pu long
terme c'est une nécessité absolue dans
les mois et des années qui viennent sur
Guyancourt deux groupes scolaires vont
être totalement réhabiliter nous avons
évidemment participé à l'effort
collectif en termes d'éclairage de
choses comme ça au sein de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines donc ça c'est
très important le très court terme parce
que c'est diverses crises ont fragilisé
encore plus les populations qui étaient
déjà fragilisées voilà on va continuer à
les fragiliser probablement avec la
réforme des retraites mais c'est un
autre sujet effectivement
et donc on se doit de réagir et les
communes sont en première rideau de de
toutes ces fragilités le maire et le
premier lien avec les habitants est-ce
que vous avez beaucoup d'habitants
aujourd'hui qui viennent vous voir et
qui sont fortement touchés par cette
hausse du cou des énergies oui c'est
très flagrant voilà pour vous donner une
petite idée alors quelques chiffres
simplement en très rapidement on a dû
augmenter nos aides de 50 % dans le
cadre des budgets des CCAS du budget du
CCAS par exemple avec l'ensemble des
aides que j'ai parce que elle est c'est
fragilité encore une fois elles sont
concrètes et elles sont immédiates voilà
les répercussions je pars notamment des
des habitants du parc social de la ville
ont vu leur provision de charge
immédiatement augmenter de manière très
importante très importante et ces
personnes qui étaient déjà fragilisées
encore une fois ne l'oublions jamais
voilà le son encore davantage et
d'ailleurs en septembre dernier vous
aviez interpellé des bailleurs sur la
hausse du prix du chauffage alors où
est-ce que ça en est ce dossier il
avance doucement trop trop doucement à
mon goût voilà pour l'instant il y a
assez peu de propositions concrètes et
immédiates on va dire son nom est
trébuchante pour pour être tout à fait
franc en revanche je pense qu'il y a une
prise de conscience réelle du fait
d'accélérer les processus de
réhabilitation énergétique voilà mais là
on a encore une fois on est un peu plus
dans le moyen terme voire pour certains
dans le plus long terme alors dans les
autres grand projet pour la commune en
2023 il y a le réaménagement du quartier
des savoirs depuis 2021 vous êtes en
concertation avec les habitants alors
quelles sont les thématiques qui les
préoccupent le plus alors effectivement
on va lancer la phase 3 de notre
concertation entamé en 2021 je le
rappelle très rapidement on avait
souhaité une grande concertation très
large et très en amont de l'arrivée des
premières entreprises et donc ça
fonctionne bien on a fait un certain
nombre d'ateliers de balades urbaine
aussi et les thèmes les thèmes
effectivement qui intéressent le plus
nos habitants c'est évidemment
l'aménagement de ce quartier soyons très
clair
va-t-il y avoir des services publics la
réponse est évidemment oui du logement
c'est évident nous savons des commerces
de l'activité économique et les
habitants sont totalement associés à
cette concertation donc le 21 janvier il
y aura la troisième phase de cette
concertation qu'est-ce que vous allez
aborder avec eux concrètement alors
concrètement il y aura une annonce très
concrète pour le coup notre nouveau
quartier il dispose et
une vraie chance d'un grand parc qui est
déjà présent bien évidemment et j'ai
souhaité que ce soit les habitants de
Guyancourt qui lui donnent son nom voilà
et donc j'annoncerai le 21 janvier donc
évidemment je ne vous le dirai pas
aujourd'hui le nom de ce parc il reste
deux noms il reste deux noms en cours
c'est Simone Veil et Marie Curie
sur sa charte d'égalité oui nous
continuerons encore alors en parlant de
nous pourquoi ce nom quartier des
savoirs
alors là aussi c'est un choix des
habitants de Guyancourt nous avions
procédé de la même manière à l'époque
par un sondage et puis de noms qui
étaient en finale je ne vous cache pas
que là immédiatement je ne me souviens
même plus du deuxième nom qui était qui
était en finale parce que le nom de
quartier des savoirs je pense qu'il y a
une référence évidente à l'activité qui
pouvait y avoir auparavant avec
l'entreprise Thalès aussi et puis je ne
vous cache pas que le fait d'aller vers
le savoir plutôt que vers le croire ou
la croyance me satisfait pleinement
autre projet d'envergure le Grand Paris
Express cette ligne de métro qui devrait
relier Orly à Versailles en 30 minutes
elle va passer par 50 ans en Yvelines et
par Guyancourt alors est-ce que est-ce
que c'est un chantier le chantier va
commencer d'ailleurs cette année comment
ça se prépare alors la Société du Grand
Paris va s'installer en 2023 voilà ça
c'est vraiment le début on va commencer
à voir des choses qui se passent
effectivement il va falloir commencer à
un moment donné à songer à creuser une
ligne de métro donc effectivement la va
s'installer on pourra le voir très très
concrètement parce qu'il y aura des des
palissades avec le nom de la Société du
Grand Paris etc
et puis on va dire que le travail un peu
masqué continue effectivement parce que
nous devons déterminer avec la Société
du Grand Paris avec l'aménageur qui est
l'établissement public d'aménagement de
Paris Saclay aussi il y a déterminer
quels sont les besoins quels seront les
besoins de ce nouveau quartier mais il
va commencer à se passer des choses
voilà les Jeux Olympiques dans dans
moins de deux ans ils auront lieu aussi
à aguyancourt sur le Golf National
pareil comment est-ce que vous vous
préparez à cette échéance alors on s'y
prépare aussi avec 50 ans en Yvelines
c'est aussi une concertation puisque les
sites olympiques sont accueillancourt
enfin le 1 si tôt olympicule mais il y
en a d'autres ailleurs dans des villes
de l'agglomération on s'y prépare il
faut qu'on crée l'événement il faut
qu'on enroule nos habitants vers cet
échéance de 2024 donc il y aura des
choses cet été par exemple à Guyancourt
mais il y a déjà eu l'été dernier un
certain nombre de manifestations autour
des des Jeux Olympiques nous avons la
chance au-delà du site olympique d'avoir
un centre préparatoire aux Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques qui sont les
salles d'arts martiaux du gymnase baquet
on va d'ailleurs en profiter pour en
refaire la piste d'athlétisme c'est
aussi dans nos projets de continuer à ça
et on espère avoir des visites de
délégation ça a déjà été le cas alors je
n'ai pas le droit de vous dire qu'il
vient visiter voilà ça fait partie des
chartes peut-être les avez-vous dans vos
informations je ne sais pas mais on a
des délégations déjà intéressées
engouement parmi les enfants notamment
la génération 2024 alors oui oui il y en
a un alors c'est évidemment avec ces
populations scolaires aussi qu'il faut
qu'on travaille on y avait déjà pensé
auparavant avec la création de la classe
golf au collège Les Saules par exemple
tous nos scolaires sont toujours
associés aux animations précédant les
événements des JO évidemment c'est
évidemment vers les scolaires qu'il faut
aller vous savez ce sont les scolaires
qui amènent leurs parents aux événements
alors sur le territoire de Guyancourt
l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines bientôt la
fusion en 2025 avec Paris Saclay est-ce
que c'est une chance pour Guyancourt
d'avoir l'UVSQ sur son territoire c'est
une chance inouï alors je vais faire
attention par les médecines à côté de
mon cher collègue mais je ne veux pas
surtout pas dire de bêtises oui c'est
une chance et il faut que nous
travaillons encore davantage avec la
faculté de médecine notamment pour
toutes les mais je veux pas les exposer
ici mais c'est une question que nous
nous posons tous sur le fait de fixer de
de de des médecins sur nos territoires
et donc il faut qu'on travaille avec la
fac quand même et alors pour terminer
cette entretien on va passer maintenant
à l'interview express
[Musique]
le principe François Morton cinq
questions et 5 réponses courtes nous
poserons les mêmes à tous les maires de
l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines alors est-ce
que vous êtes prêts
locaux dans votre commune non pour ou
contre la limitation de vitesse à 30
km/h dans votre ville nous y pour ou
contre l'obligation du bio dans les
cantines alors on a déjà beaucoup
travaillé je vais pas dire juste oui ou
non là parce qu'on a déjà pris pas mal
d'avance avec nous notre nouveau marché
de restauration qui date de juillet 2021
on va vers ça on va encore progresser et
tout ça a pris gelé parce que nous avons
souhaité je l'ai les tarifs de la
restauration scolaire pour la deuxième
année dans l'exercice de vos fonctions
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu peur
physiquement non êtes-vous un maire
heureux oui très bien merci François
Marton c'était des réponses très courtes
vous avez bien joué le jeu
de respect les règles du jeu
en tout cas merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation je le rappelle vous êtes le
maire de Guyancourt depuis des semaines
il ne cesse de tirer la sonnette
d'alarme artisan boulanger ou encore
restaurateur ils sont confrontés à la
hauteur de la de leur facture d'énergie
alors comment s'organiser t-il pour
faire face sans impacter leur client
quelle mesure attend-il du gouvernement
et les moments de réponse avec Gabriel
Gonthier et Ludivine canard des
croissants à 1 euro dépend au chocolat à
1,35 mais pour encore combien de temps
dans cette boulangerie de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux les factures
mensuelles ont été multipliées par plus
de 3,5 passant de 2000 euros à 7500
euros le compteur de 7 gérante dépassant
une certaine puissance elle n'est pas
éligible au bouclier tarifaire elle doit
donc faire face il n'est pas éligible
donc c'est en train de bouger ça va se
mettre et là on attend un petit peu de
voir qu'est-ce qui va se passer
réellement ce qui consomme le plus les
trois fours de cette boulangerie or
impossible pour cette artisane de s'en
passer
[Musique]
donner le prix du mégawater à 280 euros
un soulagement même s'il faudrait aller
encore plus loin pour se restaurateur
avec un bouclier tarifaire pour tous un
report du paiement des impôts et des
cotisations à également été annoncé les
professionnels pourront aussi résilier
sans frais leur contrat de fournitures
d'énergie en cas de hausse des prix
prohibitives alors la situation est
compliquée en vient de l'entendre pour
les boulangers les restaurateurs en ce
moment avec nous pour en parler Olivier
Girard bonsoir bonsoir Mathilde vous
êtes le président de la Fédération des
boulangers et des pâtissiers des
Yvelines alors est-ce que vous avez reçu
des désaltes de boulanger oui énormément
alors la situation est complexe parce
que en écoutant ce reportage je veux
dire tout est dit et rien n'est posé
beaucoup d'aides sont alors évidemment
je souhaite une très bonne année
évidemment à tous nos artisans
boulangers pâtissiers et tous nos
yvelinois qui nous écoutent
la problématique est énorme
aujourd'hui on nous propose des aides
mais comme toute celles-ci il y a
toujours des petits Astérix là on nous
parle d'une baisse de 380 à 280 ça
s'adresse seulement à ceux qui sont à
moins de 10 en effectif donc évidemment
ça représente que 70 ça représente 70 %
des boulangeries pâtissiers concernées
après ceux qui sont au dessus qui sont
appelés 10 évidemment ça va être très
compliqué parce que là on s'envole sur
du donc 280 on va jusqu'à 500 jusqu'à
1000 il y a un premier Bouclier qui a
été proposé justement qui peut pour
permettre voilà de retirer 20% sur
l'augmentation et évidemment il prend
pas en charge nos collègues qui
travaillent encore au bois ou au fioul
voilà donc ne peuvent pas en bénéficier
et sur le deuxième donc le guichet
automatique qui met en 20% dessus donc
ça fait pas 40 mais ça fait 20% des de
de donc on est sur du 136% et bien là
c'est pareil il faut avoir 3 % supérieur
à son consommation éner sur son bilan
par rapport à l'année dernière en
sachant que le N-1 ne correspond pas du
tout à la réalité parce que l'année
dernière nous étions encore en plein
covid donc automatiquement il y a 85 %
de boulanger qui se retrouvent avec
entre 2,57 et 2,97 donc évidemment il ne
peuvent pas prétendre encore à cette à
cette aide donc oui excusez-moi
d'une des finances publiques et il nous
avait parlé des boulangeries sur les
290 boulangeries 390 boulangeries
seulement 5 avaient demandé des aides
alors comment est-ce que vous expliquez
cela alors c'est tout simple c'est
toujours la même chose on nous parle de
numérisation sans arrêt numériser les
documents etc donc nos boulangers
passent de plus en plus de temps
derrière leur ordinateur au lieu d'avoir
la tête de dans le guidon dans leur dans
leur fourni il faut savoir que là pour
l'instant ils étaient pas tellement
concernés parce que
ils ont on a vécu le covid et sur le
covid la baisse de l'énergie n'a jamais
été aussi basse on s'est retrouvé donc
entre 5 et 10 euros du kilo donc
évidemment
je veux dire à ce moment-là des beaucoup
de contrats ont été faits et ces
contrastes terminés donc fin décembre
2022 ou sur 2023 parce que actuellement
il y a encore des boulangers qui ne sont
pas concernés par cette hausse vis-à-vis
de du fait que je veux dire il n'y a pas
eu cette augmentation vu qu'ils sont
toujours dans leur contrat mais quand
ils se sont quand ils se sont quand ils
s'alarent il est trop tard nous en 2000
fin 2021 on commence à recevoir de la
part de confédération nationale de la
boulangerie-pâtisserie en nous disant
attention en fin 2022 ça va être le
chaos et en effet on rentre dans un
chaos alors 2022 là on nous parle de
boulangerie qui ferme alors évidemment
il y a des boulangeries qui ferment
parce que le la crise énergétique bah
c'est c'est la guillotine et
on avait des boulangers pâtisseries qui
avaient cette problématique sur fin
2019-2020 et 2021 qui je veux dire on
réduit se retrouver en RJ un RJ
excusez-moi
redressement judiciaire excusez-moi donc
un redressement judiciaire c'est de
l'argent parce qu'il y a un mandataire
etc ça coûte de l'argent donc quand il y
a eu je le quoique il en coûte et le PGE
ils se sont dit mais on va elles se sont
dites ces boulangeries je vais me
redresser voilà je vais m'aider de cette
PGE le problème c'était de de comment je
veux dire de propager le mal un peu plus
loin qui s'est terminé sur 2022 donc
dedans on a des boulangeries bah
évidemment parce que en plus il y a eu
cette hausse des énergies excusez-moi
cette hausse des matières d'oeuvre des
matières premières donc voilà donc
évidemment
farine beurre je vais pas vous vous
l'avez déjà évoqué plusieurs fois dans
cette émission donc donc ça plus la
crise énergétique alors là c'est voilà
c'est ça y est c'est le c'est même plus
l'épée d'avocation comme je vous ai dit
c'est la guillotine la situation
difficile qui est devenue chaotique on
l'a compris qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait de
plus justement pour vous accompagner
parce que voilà et il y a deux choses
qu'il faut comprendre là-dessus c'est
que une boulangerie pâtisserie voilà et
je je l'espère en Yvelines et je veux
dire on en a beaucoup qui sont sur du
tout maison ça représente 35 à 50% de
masse salariale vous imaginez vous
prenez une baguette vous la coupez en
deux voilà ça c'est déjà pour ma masse
salariale donc c'est pour vous dire que
une entreprise fonctionne grâce à ses
collaborateurs ces collaborateurs qui
eux commencent excusez-moi du terme mais
vraiment à flipper parce que si on
s'annonce sur février mars et
alors évidemment par exemple un tarif
bleu c'est en dessous de 36 un four
c'est déjà entre 36 et 45 donc on est
obligé de demander un compteur spécial
qui coûte encore plus d'argent et donc
le fait c'est que ce compteur nous on
demande tout simplement et j'espère que
on sera suivi c'est que le tarif jaune
soit comme le tarif bleu donc plus 15 %
même 20% mais on sortira d'une situation
qui risque comme vous dites mais qui va
se contaminer et je veux dire on a 30000
boulangers en francs boulanger
artisanaux en France et qui crée
derrière aussi une concurrence déloyale
pourquoi parce que déjà déjà dans moi je
voilà ce matin j'avais un boulanger qui
me disait mais Olivier comment peux-tu
comprendre que dans une supérette déjà
on voit des baguettes à 60 centimes
qu'il paye déjà leur boulanger etc comme
si et leur farine qu'elle soit française
et qu'elle ne viennent pas de Pologne
etc des baguettes toutes faites avec 4
fois plus d'ingrédients que dans une
baguette de tradition française mais là
pour revenir sur sur le fait de comment
je veux dire de cette de cette
concurrence déloyale elle est toute
simple je veux dire ceux que les
terminaux de cuisson les trois plus
simples certaines supérettes sont sur le
tarif bleu vont avoir que 15%. voilà
donc automatiquement nous on pourra pas
et on sait toujours dit nous artisans
boulangers pâtissier quand vous vous
êtes très jeune mais quand il y avait le
franc c'était la baguette le journal le
café et le timbre à un franc ça c'est
fait pareil quand on est passé à l'euro
maintenant lequel des trois des quatre
est resté 1 euro la baguette pourquoi
parce que on veut que la baguette soit
encore accessible à tous nos
compatriotes parce que comme souvent
elle risque d'augmenter cette baguette
prochainement moi ce que je pense que il
va falloir que tous les acteurs jouent
le jeu parce que même aussi nos
fournisseurs parce que là les prix du
blé ont baissé alors je sais le problème
c'est que nos menhirs rencontrent aussi
des difficultés du fait que avec leur
flotte de transport ils vont être
obligés de passer à tous l'électrique
les camions électriques quand ils
arrivent tous les toutes les toutes les
semaines donc hier ils sont ils sont
obligés d'être réparés parce que en ce
moment il y a pas de fiabilité sur les
sur les moteurs électriques pour les
gros camions pour les camions qui
livrent intra-muros de donc de
l'Île-de-France donc Paris et qui va
s'étendre
et puis le fait c'est que il faut à tout
prix que cette comment je veux dire ce
tarif bleu se propage sur le sur le
tarif jaune et bien merci beaucoup
Olivier gérardons
avec nous je le rappelle vous m'avez dit
sur la baguette oui alors la baguette
alors cette baguette ce que je
souhaiterais c'est que elle reste à 1
euro il est beaucoup plus facile par
exemple sur les pins spéciaux de mettre
un peu plus d'euros parce que les gens
peuvent comprendre les pains spéciaux on
a environ sur 8 à 20 euros je veux dire
je je c'est voilà c'est un constat donc
là on ne sait plus facile de mettre par
exemple 50 centimes sur les pins
spéciaux que de mettre remettre 10
centimes sur la baguette blanche parce
que il y a un truc qui est tout simple
qu'il faut pas oublier là Monsieur
monsieur Morteau le rappeler c'est très
bien on a une population
dans le besoin bon nous on veut que les
que ces gens-là que cette population
mange du pain frais et du bon pain
qu'est-ce qui va se passer c'est que une
baguette à 1 euro 50 vous en prenez deux
pour la famille ça fait trois euros les
gens qui travaillent qui touchent entre
900 et 1300 euros vous leur mettez 100
euros je veux dire de plus 100 euros en
pain c'est un budget ça faut pas
l'oublier c'est pour ça que c'est un
problème sociétal c'est que là
aujourd'hui on allait savoir faire
artisanaux qui sont reconnus par
l'UNESCO et demain qui est-ce qui va
faire cette baguette vu qu'il y aura
plus de boulangers artisans donc la
baguette ne devrait pas trop augmenté
mais les autres baguettes j'aimerais que
mes confrères et j'aimerais aussi que
nous fournisseurs agissent là-dessus
mais c'est là je parle en tant que voilà
en tant que Président j'aimerais que
cette baguette vous savez comme certains
prix voilà on touche pas trop au
croissant on pain au chocolat on touche
pas trop je veux dire à certains
sandwichs etc pour que mais
malheureusement ils vont être obligés à
un moment ou un autre parce que c'est
pas logique là on double dit c'est fois
4 vous imaginez vous arrivez au magasin
je vous dis tiens va-t-il la baguette 4
euros vous allez me dire mais attendez
bah oui je fais comme voilà comme eux x
4 merci Mathilde merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup Oli déjà d'être venu en parler
en plateau avec nous il n'y a pas que
les boulangeries qui sont en difficulté
en ce moment depuis plusieurs semaines
certains médecins généralistes font
grève ils demandent notamment une hausse
du prix des consultations également qui
passeraient de 25 à 50 euros pour en
parler erikala jeunesse bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes médecin alors la hausse du
montant de la consultation qui passerait
de 25 à 50 euros est-ce que pour vous
c'est une bonne solution
ce n'est pas une solution déjà à la base
d'abord c'est pas une revendication qui
est portée par l'ensemble de la
profession mais c'est la revendication
qui a été retenue par l'ensemble des
médias on ne parle que de ça alors que
la réalité du mouvement de grève et les
paliers à une augmentation tarifaire
même si cette augmentation est
parfaitement légitime on est aujourd'hui
les médecins les moins bien payés
d'Europe donc il est tout à fait
légitime non seulement de revaloriser le
montant de cette consultation qui je le
rappelle et notre seul acte le médecin
généraliste n'a pas d'acte technique il
est payé c'est un acte intellectuel et
tout au long de ces dernières années on
a vu une dévalorisation des professions
de vocation et notamment de la teint
intellectuelle donc il est parfaitement
légitime que cet axe soit réévalué mais
ce n'est pas la seule revendication nous
voyons le système de santé allait dans
le mur ça fait des années qu'on tire le
signal d'alarme et nous ne sommes pas
entendu
parmi les revendications qui
sous-tendent notre mouvement il y en a
beaucoup qui ne sont pas qui ne sont pas
mis en valeur quand on voit que en
Île-de-France plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de patients qui sont en
affection longue durée c'est-à-dire des
gens qui ont des maladies chroniques des
maladies graves n'ont pas de médecins
traitant vous croyez qu'on peut se
satisfaire dans notre profession
j'entendais le boulanger qui veut donner
du bon pain aux Français ben nous on
veut donner des bons soins à nos
patients et on veut que tous nos
patients soient bien soignés donc
l'augmentation du montant de la
consultation c'est pas pour doubler nos
revenus c'est pour prendre plus de temps
parce que nous avons des pathologies de
plus en plus complexes à traiter et
d'autre part aussi le fait que notre
profession soit de moins en moins
attractive fait que nos jeunes collègues
ne s'installent pas et le vrai problème
aujourd'hui n'est pas tellement le
manque de médecin formé c'est le manque
de médecins qui s'installe savez-vous
que l'on forme depuis on a formé depuis
10 ans 45000 médecins seuls 10% se sont
installés alors vous pouvez augmenter le
numerus exclusion autant que vous voulez
tant que cette profession ne sera pas
attractive
ces jeunes médecins ne s'installent je
l'explique de manière très simple le
métier n'est plus attractif ces
conditions d'exercice deviennent de plus
en plus complexes quand si vous voulez
on nous dit et ça fait des des décennies
que ça dure que on demande des
simplifications par exemple dans le dans
les tâches administratives on nous dit
on va vous permettre d'embaucher des
assistants pour traiter chez ces tâches
administratives enfin c'est quand même
ridicule pourquoi ne pas supprimer tout
simplement c'est achat administratif moi
je n'ai pas besoin d'un assistant qui va
faire des lettres à la sécu toute la
journée ou régler des problèmes
administratifs j'ai besoin
éventuellement d'un assistant qui met
dans mon travail médical donc si vous
voulez ces fausses bonnes idées qui
consistent à nous à nous proposer de
l'aide pour nos tâches administratives
supprimons-les qu'on consiste à déléguer
à des non médecins des tâches médicales
c'est extrêmement préjudiciable à la
santé de nos patients il n'y a pas de
petites ou de grande médecine il y a la
médecine ça s'apprend dix ans et on ne
peut pas dévoyer comme ça le soin
dégradé l'offre de soins je vous
rappelle quand même que la France est un
des pays qui paye le plus cher pour sa
santé les gens n'ont pas pour leur
argent et ça fait des décennies que ça
dure et ça fait des décennies qu'on le
dénonce et ça fait des décennies que
l'on donne de avec toute la sincérité du
monde de très mauvaises réponses à
d'excellentes questions donc il serait
temps qu'on écoute un petit peu la
profession elle a des choses à dire et
s'il est regrettable si vous voulez que
ne soit mise en avant que l'augmentation
des honoraires de 25 à 50 euros même si
cette augmentation peut paraître
légitime
installation pourrait croire que c'est
une problématique qui touche plutôt la
province mais rien que dans les Yvelines
c'est aussi une réalité bien sûr les
déserts médicaux ont dit il y a des
déserts médicaux en France d'abord avant
les déserts médicaux il y avait des
déserts tout court c'est à dire que s'il
suffisait de planter un médecin pour que
pour faire reculer le désert comme je le
dis on en mettrait un tous les 10 km
dans le Sahara et il y aurait plus de
désert donc déjà si vous voulez l'idée
de dire que moi pendant 20 ans j'ai
entendu dire oui les médecins veulent
s'installer sur la Côte d'Azur c'est pas
vrai il y a aujourd'hui des airs
médicaux sur la Côte d'Azur comme
partout ailleurs la vraie question c'est
pourquoi on a formé 45000 médecins en
disant et pourquoi il y en a que 5000
installés moi c'est ça la vraie raison
et quand tant qu'on ne rendra pas
l'installation attractive tant qu'on
incitera pas nos jeunes collègues à
s'installer et c'est pas avec des
mesures coercitives comme celles que
l'on voit arriver ou des mesures qui
consistent à déléguer des soins que on
va inciter nos collègues à s'installer
voilà alors selon la Fédération
française des médecins généralistes 11%
des patients de plus de 17 ans n'ont pas
de médecins généralistes et la moyenne
nationale est de 800 patients par
médecin vous quel est votre nombre de
quel est votre patientèle moi je au
dernier je regarde pas ma patientèle
tous les jours mais la dernière fois que
j'ai regardé on devait être autour de
je n'en ai pas vraiment entendu parler
mais je crois que mes collègues sont
plutôt aux alentours de de des chiffres
comme ceux que je viens de citer 1500
entre 1500 mirandusion entre 1300 et
2000 patients voilà en général c'est
plutôt ce ce
chiffre là que que je retiens c'est
assez considérable oui c'est assez
considérable et si on met en place un
certain nombre de dispositions comme
ceux qu'on a entendu par exemple de
déléguer à des infirmiers de pratiquer
avancées des soins sous l'autorité d'un
médecin c'est plus 1500 patients c'est
10000 qu'il va falloir gérer dont plus
des 4/5 qu'on n'aura jamais vu donc si
vous voulez si le système de santé que
l'on paye fort cher aujourd'hui c'est
pour c'est pour arriver à ce niveau de
dégradation nous on n'est pas d'accord
refuser beaucoup aujourd'hui de passion
moi je enfin vous savez c'est très
difficile de dire de refuser moi je ne
refuse pas de recevoir j'étais élevé à
au biberon des soins que l'on doit
donner que l'on doit offrir mais si vous
voulez forcément il y a un certain
nombre de patients qui ne trouvent pas
de réponse alors demande et on voit bien
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui à la maison
médicale de garde de Montigny qui est en
grande souffrance aussi et il faudrait
aussi qu'on puisse en parler ou la
majeure partie des gens qui consultent
en dehors des heures d'ouverture des
cabinets ne consulte pas pour des
problèmes urgent mais parce qu'ils n'ont
pas pu avoir accès à leur médecin
traitant donc des gens viennent le soir
on n'est plus dans de la consultation
permanence de soi on est dans de la
consultation de nuit ou du week-end ce
qui n'a rien à voir et et sur le nombre
de patients qui augmentent de manière
exponentielle le plus souvent on est
amené à avoir des patients qui n'ont pas
pu consulter leur médecin traitant
pratique des déserts médicaux est très
préoccupants dans les Yvelines vous le
disiez à l'instant Grégory nous sommes
allés demander aux îles Linois s'ils
avaient des difficultés pour trouver des
médecins les propos recueillis par
Julien Leroy et Ludivine canard moi j'ai
pas été confronté directement parce que
moi j'ai la chance d'être suivi par un
médecin depuis plusieurs années et quand
elle est partie à sa retraite ça
remplaçant donc à repris forcément tous
ces dossiers oui j'ai essayé de prendre
de vous récemment en janvier du 2
finalement j'ai eu rendez-vous le 9 donc
il y a quand même une semaine de
différence fait en cas d'urgence c'est
vraiment pas comment faire c'est pas
simple non j'ai pas j'ai pas eu de
complications pour pour aller chez le
médecin dans le sens où je suis pas je
suis pas malade mon médecin généraliste
est parti en retraite avec sa collègue
depuis le 31 décembre et depuis donc
c'est un gros gros problème pour trouver
un remplaçant ou une remplaçante je n'ai
pas eu à prendre de rendez-vous pour
l'instant mais mon médecin est parti à
la retraite donc je n'ai plus de médecin
traitant alors j'ai la fille d'une amie
qui vous allez de médecine et je serai
une de ses premières patientes avec mes
enfants alors comment comment remédier à
ce manque de médecin et récalingenèse
vous nous expliquer augmenter
l'attractivité du métier mais est-ce
qu'il y a des pistes concrètes
elles viennent du terrain on a donné un
certain nombre d'idées la médecine ne
s'exerce plus comme dans les années 50
ou avant ou il suffisait d'avoir un
stéthoscope et puis une bonne oreille
pour faire de la médecine aujourd'hui la
médecine a besoin de plateau technique
elle a besoin d'accessibilité elle a
aussi besoin de rapport avec l'hôpital
je dirais on a il y a une sorte de
frontière entre la médecine de ville et
l'hôpital il faut rompre cette frontière
nous permettre d'avoir une une
un échange et des dialogues avec nos
collègues hospitaliers qui soient
facilité pour améliorer la prise en
charge de nos patients il y a tout un
toutes ces mesures là si vous voulez qui
sont des mesures de bon sens mais qui
inciteraient nos jeunes collègues à
s'installer il n'est pas normal que
entre 80 et 90% de nos collègues formés
s'installent vous pouvez doubler le
numéro exclusif on aurait au bout du
compte pas plus qui s'installe donc
incitons nos collègues à s'installer
mais pour que les inciter à s'installer
il faut des mesures pour favoriser
l'installation mais il faut surtout
rendre la profession attractive or c'est
exactement le contraire qu'on fait et
depuis des années je n'ai pas encore ce
gouvernement ni les autres ça fait 25
ans depuis les ordonnances Juppé qu'on
casse le système de santé la médecine de
ville il serait temps peut-être
d'inverser la vapeur avant qu'il ne soit
trop tard cette
grève
elle a fonctionné des choses ont été
dites des manifestations étaient faites
on verra ce que ça donnera dans les
jours suivants moi je ne doute pas de la
bonne volonté lorsque il m'est arrivé de
discuter avec des personnes qui avaient
des responsabilités politiques les
personnes que j'ai en face de moi
étaient sincères c'est-à-dire que midi
mais oui vous avez ce problème ou à le
régler comme ça vous avez trop de monde
et ben on va déléguer aux pharmaciens on
va déléguer des infirmiers on va laisser
les kills travailler mais attendez on
est où là c'est c'est la médecine c'est
de la médecine c'est pas de la
kinésithérapie c'est pas le rôle d'une
infirmière de faire le travail du
médecin c'est ma mère qui était de
l'ancienne école disait souvent un
proverbe chacun son métier les vaches
sont bien gardés et bien la médecine ça
s'apprend dix ans en étude mais ensuite
il y a toute l'expérience d'une vie et
ça ça ne se remplace pas par de la bonne
volonté même si des personnels peuvent
faire un certain nombre de tâches
médicales je ne dis pas le contraire
mais considérer que on va transformer la
médecine en autre chose et bien ce n'est
pas défendre l'intérêt de nos patients
et nous ce qui nous tient à cœur et les
augmentations d'honoraires c'est non pas
pour gagner plus d'argent c'est pour
passer plus de temps avec nos patients
avoir plus de temps à leur consacrer
parce qu'aujourd'hui avec 25 euros de
consultation il faut voir entre trois et
quatre patients à l'heure et ça n'est
pas suffisant donc nous voulons prendre
du temps et nous voulons que nos jeunes
collègues s'installent pour prendre en
charge tous ces patients qui n'ont pas
de médecin traitant et ça c'est possible
il faut rendre le métier attractif il
faut redonner cette lettre de noblesse à
la médecine générale et quand on leur a
fait peut-être qu'à ce moment-là nos
jeunes collègues ont envie de
s'installer de faire ce merveilleux
métier parce que très sincèrement moi
j'ai entendu beaucoup de sirènes aussi
ce n'est autour de moi pour faire autre
chose je suis resté là parce que on fait
un métier formidable et nos collègues le
savent et le partage et ce que nous
voulons faire au travers de ce mouvement
c'est défendre ce merveilleux métier et
donner à nos jeunes collègues envie de
le faire avec nous
merci
Eric Alain Genest d'être venu en parler
en plateau avec nous je le rappelle vous
êtes médecin à Montigny le Bretonneux on
reste dans le domaine de la médecine
mais cette fois-ci on s'intéresse au
tout petit un sujet un peu plus léger
Déborah Agnès vous êtes infirmière
puéricultrice et vous pratiquez des
bains pour les bébés alors vous
expliquer aussi aux parents comment
faire un bain et quels sont quels sont
les bienfaits de ces bains alors le but
du bain thalasso où le bain
thérapeutique c'est le nom que lui a
donné d'ailleurs sa créatrice
c'est vraiment de de pouvoir permettre
aux bébés de retrouver les sensations
qu'il avait pendant la pendant la
grossesse dans le ventre de maman pour
débloquer les mémoires utero et donc lui
permettre d'aller
débloquer s'il y a des choses
émotionnelles il peut y avoir une
grossesse difficile ou une naissance un
peu compliquée ou ça peut être aussi
très bien une grossesse qui se passe
très bien mais il y a souvent des choses
à débloquer que ça soit émotionnellement
ou au niveau corporelle et ce temps où
il retrouve ses sensations là leur
permet de revivre ces instants là et
d'aller du coup peut-être les vivre de
façon différemment comme lui bébé avait
besoin et envie de le vivre et de et de
le faire et donc les bienfaits on les a
dès le premier bain ou est-ce qu'il faut
en faire plusieurs en général un seul
suffit enfin moi j'en ai jamais fait
plusieurs
dans le sens où il y a d'abord un
échange avec les parents donc je sais
comment s'est passé la grossesse je sais
comment s'est passé la naissance ça me
donne des pistes aussi de savoir
potentiellement ce qui je vais aller
travailler dans le bain et
potentiellement comment va réagir bébé
même si des fois c'est complètement
différent parce que le but c'est
vraiment de laisser bébé libre de ses
mouvements de lui expliquer on j'ai un
petit entretien aussi avec bébé avant de
rentrer dans l'eau en lui disant voilà
c'est ton moment à toi papa et maman
m'ont raconté de certaines manières mais
peut-être que toi tu l'as vécu
différemment et là tout de suite le but
c'est que
de les laisser libre de leur mouvement
et leur dire voilà moi je suis juste là
pour que tu sois en sécurité dans l'eau
je ne te lâche pas tu peux me faire
confiance moi je te fais confiance
totalement mais je te suis c'est
vraiment toi qui va induire les
mouvements et voilà en tout cas on le
voit sur les images les bébés ont l'air
bien détendus pendant pendant le bain
jusqu'à quel âge on peut faire ce bain
là alors moi en tout cas je le pratique
comme ça je le fais jusqu'à un mois du
bébé je sais que certaines de mes
collègues le font jusqu'à 6 semaines et
c'est ok il y a pas de souci c'est juste
que avant un mois les mémoires initéro
sont beaucoup plus ancrées et donc on
peut les beaucoup beaucoup mieux en tout
cas les travailler je le fais chez
certains bébés un peu plus tard quand il
y a eu des naissances difficiles ou des
choses comme ça les parents des fois au
bout enfin avant un mois c'est compliqué
d'organiser le bain parce qu'ils ont
besoin de digérer certaines choses et
tout ça donc voilà mais voilà j'aime on
aime bien en général le faire avant
trois semaines ou un mois maximum à
savoir que si bébé est né avant terme on
peut aussi repousser voilà en fonction
de la date de et donc c'est une
technique assez nouvelle finalement
ouais la formation elle a été lancée il
y a trois ans on est arrivé en janvier
là il y a trois ans donc c'est très
récent moi j'ai été formée dans les
premières
en juillet la première année où ça a été
mis en place
la seule formation du bain thalasso bébé
en tout cas et se fait par Sonia Krief
qui est la qui l'a mis en place l'école
était à Neuilly maintenant elle est à
elle est à Suresnes parce qu'ils ont
ouvert un campus
tout un panel de formation autour de la
périnatalité
mais c'est effectivement une pratique
très très récente même si elle elle est
auxiliaire de puériculture et elle l'a
pratiqué tout au long de sa carrière
donc ça fait plus de 20 ans qu'elle fait
ça sur les bébés qu'elle expérimente etc
mais en tout cas les formations c'est
très récent donc là ça commence un peu à
être connu mais effectivement c'est
encore très
récentes
est-ce que vous êtes beaucoup dans les
Yvelines justement alors on commence à
être à être un petit peu
nombreux après combien exactement je
pourrais pas vous dire après en région
parisienne c'est plus facile parce
qu'effectivement l'école est à côté donc
forcément pour l'instant moi je suis au
pôle périnatal effectivement à Montigny
avec des collègues qui sont vraiment
spécialisés en périnatalité
malheureusement je vais pu y être très
longtemps je vais baser à plaisir à
partir de de mars avril mais toujours
dans cette optique de travail voilà
exactement je reste dans les Yvelines je
suis pas très très loin voilà ça mais
voilà le but c'est va toujours être de
travailler en équipe pour que s'il y a
un souci ostéo je puisse ma collègue
s'il y a un souci en allaitement que je
puisse renvoyer sur une conseillère en
lactation enfin voilà le but c'est
vraiment de travailler en réseau et de
pouvoir réorienter les parents en
fonction de leurs questionnements et
leurs difficultés et bien merci beaucoup
Déborah Agnès pour toutes ces
informations je le rappelle vous êtes
infirmière puéricultrice à Montigny le
Bretonneux comme chaque mercredi c'est
l'heure maintenant de passer à notre
page au cinéma
on commence par le coup de cœur d'un
professionnel cette semaine c'est
l'auteur du livre l'histoire du cinéma
pour les nuls Vincent Mirabel qui vous
propose son coup de coeur regardez
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de vous faire
découvrir un film méconnu injustement
méconnu la révolution silencieuse de
l'allemand l'art Crown c'est un film qui
est sorti en 2018 juste avant le
confinement autant dire que il n'a pas
bien été distribué et pourtant il est du
niveau de ses grands films allemands
comme la vie des autres ou goodbye
Lénine la révolution silencieuse c'est
l'histoire de 19 jeunes lycéens d'une
classe d'une petite ville d'Allemagne de
l'Est on est six ans avant la
construction du mur et ces Allemands de
l'Est picousaient au régime soviétique
vous montrer solidaire des Hongrois qui
se révoltent à Budapest ils vont
simplement imposer une minute de silence
dans leur classe et le film la
révolution silencieuse aborde toutes les
conséquences de cette minute de silence
et c'est là que l'histoire devient
passionnante parce qu'en traitant ce
sujet le réalisateur aborde la question
de l'engagement et des conséquences de
ces actes et voilà pourquoi la
révolution silencieuse est un grand film
qui nous fait réfléchir tout en nous
captivant l'histoire est remarquable
elle va par palier successifs mené à des
conséquences importantes et le générique
final nous montrera que l'aventure est
belle pour tous ces jeunes c'est un film
très intéressant pour les adultes comme
pour les jeunes lycéens je vous le
recommande vivement larscromeux 2018 la
révolution silencieuse c'est avoir dès
que vous pouvez
[Musique]
on poursuit cette page au cinéma avec
vous Grégory canalet alors quels sont
les films à ne pas manquer cette semaine
alors je vais vous faire voyager avec
ces sorties de la semaine à débuter avec
un compte l'envol de Pietro Machello
nous ramène à la toute fin de la
Première Guerre mondiale un soldat
rescapé Raphaël incarné par Raphaël
Thierry revient dans son village du nord
de la France sa femme est morte
lorsqu'il était au front et l'homme
découvre alors qu'il a lui a laissé une
fille Juliette qui est jouée par
Juliette Jouan grandit seul avec son
père elle est passionné par la musique
le chant est une grande rêveuse elle va
faire la rencontre un été et d'une
magicienne qui lui promet qu'un navire
viendra un beau jour l'emmener loin de
son village le film est adapté du roman
les voiles à zécarlats d'Alexander green
il est à mi-chemin entre la fable
fantastique et également la comédie
musicale mais la banque tout de même
Mathilde de quelques thématiques sombres
comme le viol et la mort
[Musique]
elle m'a dit que dans le village où
personne ne croyait à la magie sauf toi
[Musique]
un film franco-italien à présent Grégory
l'italien avec l'accent espagnol je sais
pas si ça vous donne envie allez
pourquoi pas
d'Emmanuel et cleanaise elle joue Clara
borgetti alors l'histoire se déroule
dans la Rome des années 1970
personnellement c'est une ville que
j'adore Rome alors Clara et son mari
felicher sont un couple qui se déchire
il ne s'aime plus mais ne se quitte pas
pour autant une situation qui affecte
grandement cette femme qui trouve refuge
dans l'amour de ces trois enfants elle
entretient d'ailleurs une relation
particulière et très fusionnelle avec
son aîné Adriana qui préfère qu'on
l'appelle Andrea le prénom est masculin
car il n'est pas né dans le bon corps
malgré les thématiques lourdes que sont
là les violences conjugales et la
société machiste l'hymensita est avant
tout une ode à la liberté
[Musique]
et pour terminer Grégory une comédie
dans le temps à Rome est désormais je
vous emmène dans les Cyclades en Grèce
un petit coin de paradis choisi par deux
copines de collège pour se retrouver 20
ans plus tard et partir en vacances
ensemble dans les Cyclades de Mark
Fitoussi on retrouve au casting lors
calami Olivia côte est également la
Britannique naturalisée Française
Christine Scott Thomas inséparable dans
leur jeunesse les deux femmes vont
découvrir qu'elles sont désormais deux
opposés d'un côté l'extraverti de
l'autre la plus réservée et elles ont
une approche très différente des
vacances et même de la vie
est attendu par sa maman au comptoir en
formation
bah oui
compliqué les séparations et après ce
voyage tu te rappelleras même plus de
son nom
[Applaudissements]
de potes qui me disent que je suis
bruyante je m'aime une pote qui
m'appelle acouphène tu vois mais là tu
as payé pourquoi dans le premier arrêt
du bateau et puis nous on est sans plus
tard
merci beaucoup Grégory canalet est-ce
que vous avez une préférence dans ces
trois films
italien j'adore la ville de Rome donc
moi mon premier film on va dire c'est
l'hymensita même si les trois films ça
fait partie de ma sélection donc j'ai
quand même envie de voir ces trois films
on va dire l'immensita en premier lieu
je choisirais aussi l'hymen Sita
[Rires]
à bientôt la fin de cette
dernier petit coup d'œil à la météo de
demain
matin le ciel devrait être plus vieux
sur l'ensemble du département le vent
sera également bien présent nous
devrions avoir des rafales de vent à 65
km/h au niveau des températures il fera
10 à 11 degrés en moyenne dans
l'après-midi pas de grands changements
en perspective la pluie devrait rester
au rendez-vous tout comme le vent au
niveau des températures il fera entre 11
et 12 degrés et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci pour votre fidélité je
vous souhaite une belle soirée sur TV 78
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]